bonsoir le préfet de corse a été abattu
il y a deux heures ajaccio claude
erignac a été assassiné en pleine rue
alors qu'il se rendait à un concert de
musique classique au théâtre municipal
il a été atteint de plusieurs balles de
calibre 9 mm pour l'instant cet attentat
n'a pas été revendiqué
c'est le premier assassinat d'un haut
fonctionnaire de l'état dans l'île ont
rejoint tout de suite jean marc leccia
dans notre station d'ajaccio jean marc
un important dispositif de police a été
mise en place
mais que sait-on exactement des
circonstances de cet attentat
on va voir d'ailleurs les premières
images qui nous parviennent à l'instant
oui d'après les premières informations
que nous avons pu recueillir sur place
le préfet de région claude erignac se
rendait à un concert dans un quartier de
la ville l'une dans une salle de
spectacle il venait de déposer son
épouse et venait de garer son véhicule
c'est au moment semble-t-il où ils
regagnaient la salle de spectacle que
deux personnes deux silhouettes jeunes
selon un témoin l'on croisé et ont fait
feu sur lui
claude erignac a été atteinte de
plusieurs balles de calibre atome de
calibre 9 mm semble-t-il pistolet
automatique une arme une arme de poing a
été retrouvée sur place on ignore encore
l'origine de larmes s'agit s'agit-il de
larmes date des tueurs ou bien de larmes
qui aurait pu posséder et détenir le
préfet lui-même est ce que les tueurs
étaient masqués jean-marc on ignore pour
l'instant le témoin ne l'a pas précisé
en tout cas pas à notre connaissance
est ce qu'on a déjà à des premières
pistes pour l'instant c'est vrai
l'attentât n'a pas été revendiqué mais
ce qu'on a déjà des premières pistes
écoutez pour l'heure toutes les pistes
j'imagine de la part des enquêteurs
pourront être et exploiter rien ne
laisse ne laissait prédisposait près ce
présupposé plutôt excusez moi en corse
ces dernières semaines ce ce type d'acte
il peut s'agir d'une piste politique
comme il peut s'agir d'une piste tout à
fait autre d'origine complètement
crapuleuse ou ou purement
sauvage rillettes donc pour l'instant
mais n'est privilégiée à notre
connaissance en tout cas parler par les
enquêteurs vers sa marque cela faisait
deux ans que claude erignac était en
poste sur l'île
comment était-il perçu écouter claude
erignac est arrivé effectivement en 1904
début 1996 il a traversé diverses
périodes mouvementées de de la région
corse des des climats très trouble des
climats de de violence le climat s'était
quelque peu apaisées ces derniers mois
lui même en serviteur de l'état s'était
adapté aux changements politiques
intervenus
il était un interlocuteur régulier est
tout à fait classique semble-t-il de la
classe politique corse mais aussi du
monde associatif du monde de
socioprofessionnels qu'il rencontre est
assez souvent et il faisait partie de
deux de ces préfets qui ont eu à traiter
de dossiers socio-économiques dans des
périodes troubles assez important on va
à priori recevoir de nouvelles images
sur cet attentat donc je le disais aussi
il ya un important dispositif qui a été
mis en place un dispositif de sécurité
tout le quartier a été bouclé jean-louis
toutou quartier bouclé ce qui est tout à
fait normal compte tenu des
circonstances
compte tenu de la personnalité de la
victime
cela fait partie des choses
habituellement des dispositifs
habituellement mises en place dans des
cas pareils et ajaccio hélas même si
c'est la première fois vous le rappeliez
qu'un haut fonctionnaire de l'état y que
le représentant de l'état en corse est
assassiné à ajaccio rsa a connu d'autres
d'autres drames
mais a priori les tueurs connaissait
bien l'itinéraire de claude erignac puis
s'ils se rendaient au théâtre c'était
vraiment un déplacement purement privée
selon toute vraisemblance il pourrait
effectivement s'agir de quelque chose
d'organisé puisque
il fallait savoir que le préfet de
région se rendent effectivement à ce
spectacle même si le préfet de région se
déplacer régulièrement des actions comme
tout citoyen pour se rendre à des
spectacles je vous le disais très
souvent et très régulièrement
merci beaucoup jean-marc pour tous ces
commentaires